when you and i
met we're hanging out we made this video
the fact that the
the fake ball sack coming out of my
jeans with all the fake blood
the fact that that video got demonetized
really affected you you were like [ __ ]
there was this d
and then and then at that same sort of
moment in
youtube there was what was called
adpocalypse is that right like
where they found like super like hateful
content
like associated with certain brands and
then the brands were like yo
youtube you just put my uh you just put
my coca-cola ad on like
some kind of isis they put it on isis
videos are they really
yeah and then all of a sudden all of a
sudden like youtube youtube
put it on terrorist propaganda videos
and coke was like dude
i don't even know if it was cooked but
but you know just said it was yeah it
was it was like pepsi
coke it was how does isis have a youtube
channel like they have a lot of stuff
that's what pokemon yeah and there was
that yeah and to be honest there was
it was kind of a what like looking back
pre adpocalypse
youtube was a pretty wild place isis had
a youtube channel and they had vid
and ads on it dude it was called isis
right
coca-cola coca-cola was directly funding
terrorism
through this dude was there a youtube
channel called
isis i don't [ __ ] know no it was
called like uh
you know what if i even joke i'm going
to come out like an [ __ ] but it
wasn't called isis
so youtube can kind of over correct you
know
like youtube takes the the stance of
like
all right if it's even remotely in
question it's demonetized
sure very broad strokes and at that time
i remember
ethan as well as like a whole bunch of
youtubers
like really like feeling the squeeze you
know it was like wait a second oh yeah
you know like back then our
we were making like 100 of our income
was from
youtube revenue which is really dumb
you're like it's really not well
diversified
but we didn't we were just like happy
with it you know our adsense was good
and we were happy with it
and so all of a sudden the apocalypse
comes about and i would say
90 of our income disappeared in you know
one day
wow so which is kind of insane because
we let's say we're making like a hundred
thousand dollars a month
in that sense we're stoked on it's good
money and then also we're making
wow and then all of a sudden we're
making 10 000 which is a lot of money
but like you have employees you have
a house that you're renting with the
assumption that you're making
a hundred thousand dollars a month and
ten thousand dollars a month isn't
enough to pay the [ __ ] bills that you
have
when you go when you lose that much
income so it was a big uh
kind of a panicky situation for us how
long have you turned to correct turn
turn he's trying to the podcast that was
the crash why
the podcast was the correction honestly
they're still correcting it
but but it's gotten much better
obviously back then it was just like
everybody's just yellow yellow yellow
yellow unless you're making like uh
minecraft content for kids yeah
dude